collonges au mont d'or à quelques
kilomètres de lille tout gastronomes
connaît cette adresse c'est celle de
paul bocuse empereur de la nouvelle
cuisine française
paul bocuse tout commence au marché
qu'il fait lui-même aussi souvent que
les exigences de sa renommée le lui
permettent
en effet le grand chef français réclamé
partout dans le monde aussi bien à new
york à tokyo
mais il est vrai aussi que paul bocuse
semble doué du don d'ubiquité temps son
énergie lui permet de mener de front les
devoirs de sa charge et les plaisirs de
sa vie privée personnages importants de
cette vie privée les six chiens qui
vivent à ses côtés et que tout en
gardant un oeil sur les casseroles
il a bien voulu nous présenter
où
tout m'a plu
nelson
celui-ci l'a71 un jeune labrador qui
bien ces trois veaux qui me donnait mais
il n'a pas encore chasser serait de sa
première année de chasse cette année
mais j'aime beaucoup les voix d'or c'est
un chien formule est formidable j'ai un
braque allemand là mais sera calme en
est très conscient
s'il a des parents formidables et
malheureusement il a fort des coups de
fusils il a peur des trains et l'apport
de tous et c'est très difficile dans un
chien peureux et là il ya rien à faire
un peu d'être avec ma famille les fumées
avec moi les très difficile quand on a
des chiens bien sûr il faut avoir un
espace quand on vit avec des chiens
l'abattement je pense pas que les chiens
ont un poil aussi brillant maire fera
tout le monde peut pas avoir aucun chez
mangent de l'herbe on leur donne une
soupe par jour qui sont quand même
toujours un petit peu gras chez nous
parce que y'a quand même l'abondance
mais enfin dès que la chasse mais l'île
verte
ils reprennent leur leur ligne
produite par jour et avec de la viande
du riz les carottes un peu de légumes et
peu d'huile d'olive et on leur donne de
moins manger les teknivals
mon corps a toute une histoire
sa mère était donc la traite fameuse
chienne labrador que j'ai gardé pendant
18 ans et pendant 14 ans elle a jamais
voulu un mâle de labrador est à sa
quinzième année y est venu un jour le
chien-loup du voisin et ils se sont
mariés tous les deux et voilà ce que ça
a donné
donc c'est un labrador moi qui ai
chien-loup moitié labrador
ça c'est le mori mori connus mais les
mélanges ayant repris il ya peu le noir
pour un poids de l'indicé mais tu as vu
c'est fait noir était mon père bruyère
jetant des cas et pour qu'on me dit
lassé du kremlin dans notre restaurant
quand un client vient avec un chien en
général on y fait très attention parce
que du moment que cette dame bien avec
son chien
je pense que ce chien vit avec elle
vient souvent couche dans l'eee elle le
considère un peu comme son enfant et je
trouve normal qu'on s'occupe du chien
alors dès qu'il arrive il a un petit
nous on accepte les chiens dans notre
restaurant boucle nous resterons
n'accepte pas de chien mais des fois il
vaut mieux avoir un chien qui soit
tranquille d'un restaurant qu'un gosse
qui pleurent volant tout le repas est
donc le chien à son petit tapis on lui
amène sa soupe et en général ils ça se
passe très bien du moment qu on a une
belle je crois qu'il faut s'en occuper
voila voila maï maï c'est le scottish
terrier qui vit à la maison il dit avec
nous et en général il est dans la maison
laure est un petit peu grosse parce que
le soir à l'habitude de faire le tour de
la salle et tous les gâteaux tout ce
qu'elle trouve qu'il faut qu'elles le
volent un peu tout un mic zhuhai sont
des chiens très joueur très affectif et
très affectueux et on aime beaucoup
avant la vérité quelle poils longs elle
était quel bien sûr est mort très vieux
et les morts aussi à 15 ans est là
depuis trois ans on a donc mike est là
et elle vit en permanence avec nous elle
vient avec nous quand on part donc c'est
un peu là la chouchou de la maison joue
au voilà break et négus légumes c'est
noir bien sûr rexel chien loup donc ça
ce sont deux chiens qui sont là dans la
salle buisson un peu pour la gare mais
enfin réguler c'est un chien qui
vivaient sur un balcon tu un jour on va
porter au m'a dit mais j'avais un tout
petit chien voilà ce qui est dû au fait
prix là ils ont un grand parc et rex
aussi c'est un chien qui était dans un
appartement et il ajoute ici parce que
les deux avaient deux autres avant ils
sont morts de vieillesse
ils ont été remplacés par ces deux là ya
quatre ou cinq armes et enfin qu'ils
aiment jouer il aime la balle et ils
pensent qu'à jouer mais ils gardent bien
la maison de soir ils sont très très
gentil tous les deux sont bien sûr pas
des chiens pure race mais enfin est-ce
que la race c'est quelque chose quand on
aime des animaux il adore l'eau nous
alors leur grande
c'est un peu lourd dans l'eau c'est à
croire ce sont des phoques alors soyez
d'un prix d'or voilà encore parfois
quand vous étiez par exemple tout jeune
enfant est ce que les animaux ont tenu
une place bribes bien sûr parce que mon
grand-père d'un châle ou c'est une
chienne qui s'appelle yann et ses chiens
on a la chance que les chiens vivent
très vieux chez nous il meurt toujours
les 15 16 17 18 ans donc je crois que
c'est très bien pour un chien et cette
chienne a toujours passé toute mon
enfance avec moi c'est à dire elle avait
une petite charrette elle tira la
charrette
mais jouer pour moi j'ai vécu toujours
avec des choux